the woman who sits across from me is not
my wife she looks like my wife she
smells like my wife her voice sounds
just like my wife's she eats her
breakfast just like my wife and she
feels just like my wife but I know she
isn't my wife there's something in the
eyes something in the way they shoot
around the room avoiding me it's
something in the way she speaks how her
tone flattens at the end of each
sentence there's something not quite
right and how she Saunders across the
floor swinging her hips a little too
wide lifting her feet a little too far I
don't know what that thing across the
table is but it's not my wife and I've
become increasingly convinced that it
means to kill me the changes happened
over a year ago but happily gone off
camping in the Sierra Nevada mountains
the days were spent hiking forest paths
and at night would keep each other warm
then one fateful afternoon we were
separated in a pouring thunderstorm
I lost the path and started running
through the trees searching for my wife
and the flashes of light and streaks of
darkness for hours I stumbled through
the wilderness calling for refusing to
admit that I was lost myself suddenly I
burst through the undergrowth into a
grove of tall oaks the clouds broke and
the moon spilled into the open cops
bathing it in silver light my tired legs
collapsed under me and I fell to my
knees whispering her name under my
breath Sophie Sophie where are you
suddenly a voice cut through the cold
night air Danny is that you she stood
behind me covered in the silver light
looking like a marble statue I rose to
my feet to embrace her he spent the
night huddled together under the
towering trees the next morning as we
picked our way back to the trail was the
first time I noticed something wrong she
was leading the way she kept glancing
over her shoulder at me as if trying to
judge my expression she told me she was
worried about losing me again
at the time that was enough of an excuse
to set my mind at ease we managed to
find the trail and return to our camp
the rest of the trip crept by as I felt
an increasing sense of unease each time
I looked at her something new seemed a
little off the way she kept glancing
back unnerved me until I insisted that I
hike in front but that was no better as
I could feel her eyes boring into the
back of my skull and then like how she
inch slowly away from me as we sat
around the campfire the situation only
worsened when we returned Toa the
familiar settings her to exacerbate the
subtle inconsistencies between the
person in my house and the woman I
married whenever I was whether she
became quiet and withdrawn her once
joyous smile was reduced to the mere
four simile of a wax model I could feel
her shiver when I drew close and her
skin tensed when I touched her worst of
all she never stopped staring whenever
we were together and I was looking away
she would cast the suspicious eye on me
sometimes I would catch a reflection and
wheel around and she would glance away
and avoid eye contact with subtle
questioning I tried to bring up these
strange new habits at first but she
always slipped away from an answer as
the weeks passed I fell more
disconnected from Sophie than I ever had
before she begun to avoid me always
ducking out of a room as soon as I
entered it the tension in the house was
palpable in the back of my head I knew
something was terribly wrong but I
couldn't quite identify what it was then
one evening when she was out of town
I ran across a pile of photo albums as I
flipped through them a realization
struck me the more I stared at those old
pictures of the Sophie I once knew the
more I grew convinced the woman who had
stumbled across me in the moonlit Grove
was not my wife
she returned and as she opened the door
i sat gazing at her then make any sense
but the truth was obvious some dark
magic that night had replaced my Sophie
with a mysterious doppelganger whose
ultimate intentions I could not guess
the copy the fake through another
plastic smile at me then disappeared up
the stairs her ceaseless gaze grew a
hundred times more unbearable as I
imagined what evil intentions lurked
behind those hazel eyes I doubled my
covert observation of the thing always
keeping it in the corner of my vision
never letting it stay behind me this is
the hell I return to every day and a
night I thought I next to its curl to
form not daring to sleep must it
strangle me in the darkness thirteen
months and I couldn't stand it any
longer i begun to drink which only
served to intensify the creatures odd
behavior the form of sophie had taken to
pink sing the halls moving from room to
room in some enigmatic ritual i was
absolutely convinced that the thing
meant to kill me what else could that
strange gaze mean as it peered around
the corners and through the open
doorways of my exposed back i would turn
and i would hear her feet patter down
the hall and the door slam it was
watching me always watch
the thing and I stalked around the house
in an absurd dance of scrutiny and
evasion the few times we were in the
same room together became sessions of
awkward silences and paranoid glares by
now I'm sure the creature knew I
suspected it I had to get rid of it
alright would go mad if it didn't kill
me first my chance came from the
creature itself and had come down the
stairs one night and talk through my
wives lips of how it wanted to plant a
row of trees in the backyard that gazed
into the copy of my wife's eyes as it
asked me to dig a trench to put the
saplings in with a struggled smile I
nodded and told her I would start right
away
the horrible thing leaned forward and
kissed me on the cheek
I had to restrain myself from snapping
its neck right there I spent the next
several days digging the hole and made
it to be long and wide and deep at night
I locked myself in the study and planned
I prepared an alibi I rehearsed my next
steps the plot was to lure the creature
out to the pit kill it and bury the body
the next day I would file a
missing-persons report when the cops
came I would tell them that I had
returned home to find Sophie missing a
few weeks later they would knock on the
door and tell me regretfully that the
searchin being called off I would cry
and ball and hold a memorial service for
my wife then I would sell the house and
move on with my life
the trench was finished my plan was
ready I slipped a knife into my pocket
then walked inside Sophie I finished
digging
can you come down and tell me if the
pits big enough the thing appeared at
the dorm walked off to the pit yeah that
looks like it'll fit all the trees
actually you dug a little deeper than I
needed thanks hon no problem
I replied as I crept up behind her
reaching for the dagger in my coat
suddenly she swung around and hugged me
thanks sweetie
she beamed at me now then would you like
the honor of putting in the first tree I
turned to pick up one of my saplings my
hand creeping back towards my pocket
stealing myself for the task that lay
ahead then something heavy hit the back
of my head stars exploded before my eyes
as I fell down into it black nothingness
I woke up that was lying at the bottom
of a pit I tried to stand and you know
lies that was bound head to foot and
ropes think routes that the edge of the
pit a bloody shovel in her hand she
K'Ehleyr down at me good you're awake
now who or what the hell are you what
honey what's going on why am I tied up
don't call me honey I don't know what
you are but you're not my husband last
chance
Daniel what the hell are you I'm Daniel
mcCormick I'd be married to Sophie
McCormack for two years no I was married
to Daniel mcCormick for one year then he
and I went on a hike and got separated
he disappeared and I stumbled across you
sobbing in the forest
I swear it's me I thought that you
weren't no more [ __ ] you think I
haven't noticed you staring at me
there's a whole time you think I didn't
notice all the weird crap you were doing
every time I looked at you I saw
something wrong he didn't move right he
didn't speak right
I saw the anger in your eyes I tried
telling myself it was all my imagination
but I realized something
you aren't my husband you're just some
horrible duplicate I had to live with
you for over a year I had to [ __ ]
sleep next to you it took me a long time
to guess your intentions but when I
finally figured out you were planning to
kill me I had you take the grave grave
grave I won't ask again Danny what the
hell are you and where is my husband I'm
your husband you [ __ ] fine she began to
shovel the dirt back into the hole
Sophie no I'm your husband you have to
believe me
let me out this isn't funny Sophie I'm
Daniel mcCormick I tried to scream as
the mud filled my mouth
Sophie McCormick filled most of the hole
and carefully planted the trees and laid
saw it across the bare earth she went
inside and washed the dirt off her hands
then she called the police and filed a
missing-persons report
and the cops came she told them that she
had come home to find her husband
missing a few weeks later the cops
knocked on the door telling her that
regretfully the search had been called
off she cried and bawled and held a
memorial service for her husband
then she sold the house and moved on
with her life
the saplings grew into tall thick trees